essai
et résidentes et succédera à françois
dans quelques jours à l'elysée tient bon
denis bertrand
bonjour bonjour on le lieu s'est rempli
un petit mot sur le choix de ce lieu
mais ce qui me paraît intéressant c'est
que c'est un lieu qui est hautement
symbolique mais plus que hautement
symbolique qui multiplie les
possibilités de symbole
cette allure monarchique ce s'élargit
comme lieu de consécration de soul and
is à sion nationale et le centre du
centre en quelque sorte
et maintenant c'est devenu le lieu le
lieu de l'art à lui de la beauté au lieu
de les valeurs esthétiques des valeurs
esthétiques universelle avec la pyramide
en particulier que modernité modernité
d'universalité dollars c'est intéressant
parce que ceux-ci symbole de la culture
française emmanuel macron qui avait dit
qu'il n'y avait pas alors une culture
française
oui il n'ya pas une culture française a
été compris comme il n'ya pas de culture
française alors qu'en réalité il n'ya
pas une culture française y en a
plusieurs et c'est la pluralité et ce
lieu-là ce lieu unique en ce qu'ils
abritent les div et la diversité des
cultures artistiques
[Musique]
la culture française mais ça commence
tout de suite par des chansons en
anglais à
oui c'est vrai que c'est surprenant en
ce moment en ce lieu qu'il n'y ait pas
une animation avec des musiciens
mais surtout que la première phrase est
dit en anglais tout de suite quoi c'est
ça qui est bizarre a été surprenant
[Musique]
voilà il est à son quartier général dans
le quartier mon avis devrait pas ici
alors il rejoindra l'esplanade du bourg
et en attendant il va prononcer cette
première allocution
alors qu'il est venu ici vous avez
choisi de nous accorder votre confiance
et je tiens à vous exprimer ma profonde
gratitude
c'est un grand honneur et c'est une
grande responsabilité car rien n'était
écrit je me levais il est difficile tu
es économique ni les fractures sociales
ni les impasses démocratique ni
l'affaiblissement moral du pays
je veux ce soir adressé un salut
républicain c'est assez différent du
soir du premier tour tout à fait
différent je souhaite la gravité ont
conduit qui s'opposent à l'audience
s'étonnant d'ailleurs sa faune renversé
quasiment identiques mois front renversé
la colère l'anxiété
je vais avec humilité avec dévouement
militer c'est la réponse aux critiques
c'est marrant ça c'est vraiment
l'humilité à la place au lieu de
l'enthousiasmant impressionnant c'est
impressionnant de modestie modestie de
figure de l'amnésie pour employer une
expression c'est mieux laoghaire mais tu
restes et c'est à des coûts qui corrige
les erreurs du premier tour mais ce que
du coup il épate finalement parle pour
la circonstance et abstraction faite du
discours du premier tour étonnant
presque l'impression que la france 2
je sais que je suis une mauvaise
nouvelle c'est le discours du mauvaises
nouvelles et y avait une tête 7e
maintenant c'est vrai que l'ambiance est
assez poussive a discouru d'audition
robes et d'entendre et à mesure de cette
ambiance étrange pas tout tout ce qui ce
côté inattendu la gravité ici du sceau
de jeu là comme quelque chose aveux
ouais quand même temps c'est peut-être
ça aussi les événements historiques qui
n'ont pas l'air d'en être
message à leurs denis le message pour
l'instant il n'apparaît pas mais
peut-être qu'il dépasse peut-être un
infra message qui se produira après coup
peut-être peut-être qu'il n'est pas
directement énoncés c'est pas
inintéressant on sait pas ce que l'on
vit en fait c'est un peu comme à la
bastille avec françois hollande on joue
l événement historique et finalement ça
n'a pas été historique
c'est bizarre d'ailleurs c'est machin là
sur écran géant
conte président on dirait une marque que
tu sais on dirait une pub tu penses au
fromage président au camembert
non ça fait slogan publicitaire ça fait
cher utilisé sur ses pas une fête
populaire parce qu'il ya une prise en
charge tout et c'est un spectacle onfray
c'est pas une fête les gens sont
spectateurs de quelque chose ils sont
pas en action en fait non il n'y a pas
de rêves de structuration militante
constituer un situe au départ on avait
deux options mais qui fait un collectif
qui paye armée qui va le porter dans ses
fonctions collectif s'invente le nouveau
président d'areva blé le même réponse
[Applaudissements]
et ces petites innovations si loin que
ça
quelle mise en scène
ouais ça me fait penser à mitterrand
quand il descend tu sais dans le
panthéon seul dans les monuments
là il est filmé par ses équipes en fait
un
la cee qui filme à tapas d'autres
caméras là encore ça fait comme une
dissonance par rapport à tout ce que
probable tant de nuits
comment ça une dissonance parce que le
naturel et spontané le proche il a tout
fait qu'on a quelque chose de très
erratique gens tellement c'est quand
même très verticale ce qui l'a toujours
fait c'est lui le mouvement s'est lui
quoi on marche lui il n'y a pas que tu
dis après deux collectifs comme une
pierre quand même une sorte de
convivialité qui est m'hamdi engagé
quelque chose
jeux communautaires ce que nous avons
fait depuis tant et tant de moi a lâché
nous maintenant c'est fini tout mais je
vais donc équivalent tout le monde nous
disait que c'était impossible
melvin le connaissez pas la france je
veux de suite ce soir avoir un mot pour
les français qui ont voté pour moi sans
avoir nos idées vous vous êtes engagé et
je sais qu'il ne s'agit pas là d'un
blanc seing
je veux avoir un mot pour les français
qui ont voté simplement pour défendre la
république je sais nos désaccords
je les respecterai que je serai fidèle à
cet engagement pris je protègerai la
république
et je veux enfin avoir un mot pour ceux
qui ont voté aujourd'hui pour madame le
pen
elle n'est sifflé pas ils ont exprimé
aujourd'hui une colère un désarroi
parfois des convictions je les respecte
mais je ferai tout durant les cinq
années qui viennent pour qu'il n'ait
plus aucune raison de voter pour les
extrêmes
il faut la photo qua non à ses fans
allemands furent au final qui comme il a
voté au sénat quoi un acte hors des
personnes qui viennent
la famille avait il va nous la faire à
la sarko à lhassa j'ai toujours dit à la
sarko 2007 familles recomposées va les
enfants les petits-enfants les ailes et
les conjoints les gens
ces discours de victoire lancé un
exercice imposé il ya quand même des
variations d'un président à l'autre
alors emmanuel macron là dans son
discours de victoire il a 40 qu'elle
figure de président quel type de
président qui est discours de président
à la figure est posée je crois que ce
genre de discours cette vision du
rassemblement vers le rassemblement
c'est timo logiquement réassembler ce
qu'était 10 anglais ceux qui étaient
dispersés par la campagne les conflits
les tensions etc
et chaque semaine à prédire le critère
presque de définition de ce genre de
discours de victoire depuis les premiers
2002 pourrait-on dire depuis jacques
chirac nicolas sarkozy françois hollande
et emmanuel macron décline le motif du
rassemblement mais là c'est tout c'est
très intéressant de voir la distinction
à l'époque dans 2002 jacques chirac
rassembler sur le après face à face à
rassembler sur le critère du du destin
de la nation
le destin de la nation qui forge est le
ciment nicolas sarkozy rassemble a tenu
un discours de rassemblement autour de
d'un affect partager autour de sa propre
personne comme fédérateur de
2 du rassemblement françois hollande lui
a tenu son discours de rassemblement
autour de la souffrance je dirais plutôt
delà de la ddt de la brisure de la
fêlure de l'attitude c'est une série
d'accords et qu'on est là on a on a un
discours de rassemblement qui est plus
compliqué il a fait une sorte de
typologie qui n'est pas du tout la même
que celle de ses prédécesseurs celle de
ses prédécesseurs s'étaient ceux qui
sont avec moi et qui ont voté pour moi
et ceux qui sont contre moi et que je
rappelle que je raconte c'est ça
alors que là alors que là on avait une
subdivision à l'intérieur il ya ceux qui
adhèrent je les salue je les remercie il
ya ceux qui ont voté pour moi sans
adhérer je les salue je les remercie les
quais comme la la prise en compte d'une
partie de son électorat qui est bien une
sorte de très étonnant parce que ça
n'arrive pas sérieux les remerciements à
ceux qui ont accepté de voter pour lui
quoique n'adhérant pas avec lui
maintenant des mineurs n'avaient pas
fait les et le troisième le trump
catégorie c'est en effet les brebis
perdues gare et qu'il faudra ramener
dans le bercail qui souhaitait voter
marine le pen
donc c'est une configuration du
rassemblement qui est assez étonnante
parce qu'elle prend elle est inédite en
fait peut-être que ça explique à rebours
la gravité du premier discours dire que
ça prend en charge la complexité de la
situation face à laquelle ils se
trouvent
et bien c'est intéressant parce qu'on
voit bien que lui
début son discours a été beaucoup dans
le noir un peu dans le jeu à la fable
beaucoup dans le new début ce qui était
en rupture totale avec son discours de
soir du premier tour
et puis ça contraste complètement avec
cette mise en scène une avant cela on a
dit effectivement et beaucoup l'ont dit
immédiatement le panthéon et cet homme
comme ça seul qui marche et là
effectivement il ya un décalage là aussi
on dirait qu'il ya plusieurs signaux qui
sont envoyées qui n'a pas vraiment
choisi sur quel type de symbolique il
allait communiquer non oui tout à fait
parce que c'est même étonnant parce que
cette marche solitaire dans dans le
palais demande dans le palais puisqu'on
en est à l'ex un palais du louvre palais
du louvre
c'est même de sous le signe de l'hymne
européen qu'il fait cette grande marche
sur la nel
très étonnante en effet qu'un peu comme
comme souvent je trouve avec lui quelque
chose d'un petit peu décalé un peu
dissonant un peu disproportionné un peu
à côté on voit quelle idée mais on a un
peu l'impression qu'il n'est pas tout à
fait accompli comme il conviendrait
lorsque mitterrand allait dans le
panthéon il allait déposer une rose sur
de tomber il marchait c'est à cette
solitude face à l'histoire
mais là là il va y va vers un podium
tout simplement péri il ya quelque chose
de complètement pragmatique dans son
rapport à l'alcool mais sans forcément
faire quelque chose de très particulier
voilà la symbolique n'est pas
complètement n'est pas complètement
explicite
donc ça reste 11 16 du change en suspens